The one thing you may have noticed first in
this trailer is that they never show off Pennywise's
face in full, it's always obstructed by something.
But after going through frame by frame, I
found a subliminal message that plays for
1/12th of a second, so stick around if you
want to see that.
This opening scene with the boat seems to
show that this will be super faithful to the
source material.
This box of tissues shows us that Bill is
sick when he makes the boat.
These curtains tell us that they are in the
50s.
There seems to be a pad and pencils on Bill's
bed, perhaps a nod to the fact that Bill grows
up to be a writer in the book.
He also seems quite interested in astronomy,
though I'm not sure what to make of that.
Let me know your interpretation in the comments.
As Georgie is playing with his boat, we see
that the streets of Derry seem to be covered
with these tents, which are blocked off by
Public Works.
It looks like they may have been used to cover
up the sewage caps in the street, which may
be a result of IT.
With sandbags all around the base of these
tents, it seems they don't want anything getting
in or out.
Glad to see this scene in here, I know all
too many people who refuse to walk near sewer
grates because of this part.
It's obviously dark in there, but it seems
Pennywise may not have his signature balloons.
There are two big red arrows on the ground
pointed at this monument.
Here we see a woman putting up missing posters
for Patrick Hockstetter.
Patrick is one of the bullies in Henry Bowers'
gang who terrorizes The Losers Club.
In the 1990 TV mini-series, he is basically
just a minor character, but in the book, he
is probably the most disturbing human character
of all.
I'm going to steer clear of spoilers, but
if you've read the book, you know that things
are about to get dark.
Also, look how many staples are on this post,
just think about all the missing kids in this
town that have already been given up on.
This is obviously the library scene, but as
I recall, this scene took place when they
were adults, not kids.
It was also Richie who sees Pennywise and
the balloons in the library in the mini-series
at least.
Judging by his weight, I'd say that this character
is supposed to be Ben.
As a disclaimer, there may be things I'm forgetting
from the book, please drop me a comment if
that is the case.
But the point is, that throughout the entirety
of this trailer, we seem to only see the characters
as kids, leading me to believe that the adult
portions of the story may be cut out, or Warner
Bros. is planning to do a sequel.
Look at this shirt he's wearing, this is clearly
a reference to Stephen King's book, Christine.
The one with the killer cars.
This house is probably 29 Neibolt Street,
a run down house in the book where the kids
encounter IT in some of it's other forms.
In fact, it's basically confirmed a few moments
later when we see Neibolt St on this map of
the sewer system.
Speaking of which, we can also see that a
sewage line runs through the cemetery, which
means we may get a new adaptation of the grave
digging scene, so take your pick ba-ba-ba-Billy
boy, except for the one the end.
That's already taken.
Sorry.
It's not really clear what's going on here,
but they are basically using their projector
to display a map of Derry onto a map of the
sewer lines so they can see exactly where
the sewers line up with actual locations in
the town.
Here we see one of kids taking a puff of his
inhaler, which means that his character is
probably Eddie, the asthmatic of the group.
In the book, the inhaler becomes a weapon
used against Pennywise, and it's presence
here suggests that that may still be the case.
Earlier in the trailer we see them putting
slides in the projector.
This slide clearly says Made In USA.
Then later on, it shows a slide popping out,
and if you look closely it says Made In Canada.
Beverly wears a key around her neck and Ben
has solar systems on his shirt, a possible
connection to the planets in Bill's room.
For the rest of the trailer from this point
on, they cut to these two frames of the blank
wall upon which they were showing the projection
in between shots, if you were wondering what
that was.
If you look closely at Pennywise's reflection
right here, you'll notice that IT's eyes don't
seem to reflect in the water, which is pretty
creepy if you ask me.
You'll also notice the washer and dryer right
here, which means they aren't in sewer in
this scene, they are in somebody's flooded
basement or something.
And finally the last shot of the trailer,
we see this wall again for 1/12th of second
and the projector is now showing our first
totally unobstructed view of Pennywise's face.
And that's IT.
Pun intended.
If you are excited for this movie, then give
this video a like.
And if you're new here on the channel, my
name is CZ and I direct horror films and write
horror stories.
People have told me that I'm like the Stephen
King of the YouTube generation, so if that
sounds interesting to you, be sure to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every other week,
ring that death-bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.